4 mars 1879 l'orphelinat vient d'ouvrir
nous accueillons les premiers enfants
tout ne serait que bonheur les problèmes
de santé d'eléonore c'est l'atmosphère
des lieux pour moi qui la rend si faible
monsieur val démarre je suis navré mais
son mal et acura
il y a toujours un espoir j'ai besoin
d'un signe mon nom et alister crowley ce
chrome les commerces avec le début
votre maison a le pouvoir d'attirer les
forces occultes pour sauver votre épouse
vous devrez faire appel à des savoirs
ancestraux consignées dans le
necronomicon le livre démarrage mais
qu'est ce que le risque de noyade
ce livre se détruit le savoir des grands
anciens et là il s'agit d'un wauquiez
divinité primitive
folie mais ce rêve ou la refermer
hier sous
il ne consomme ni à la lecture de ce
livre il est peuplé de créatures symtoma
siècle que d'autres